こんにちは私が steez カープです
今日はですね日本語でなくて英語の音
英語の勉強について
具体的に日本人にとっては
英語の勉強においては何が難しいかと
それについてまず自分の考え方を
申し上げますけれどもぜひ
後で日本人の方
その自分の経験からして
その英語の勉強の相手何が一番
その問題点なのかと
ぜひご意見を聞きたいと思います
が私自分の意見ではですねもちろんもう日本人じゃないですし
英語はその外国人として勉強したこともないんです
だからええ
その経験はないけれども自分が日本語という英語と全然違う言葉を
その勉強したその
経験があるから
ある程度まあ想像すると思いますまあこれ
また全然間違ってるかも知れば知りませんけれども
自分の考え方家を持ち上げます
まず1つはですねだけども是非みなさんの意見を聞きたいんです
まず1つはですねー
その英語を勉強するときにですねあるいは私が
日本語を勉強するときに考えておかないといけないのはですね
その違った言葉というは
戦略において場所なんですよというのは私は実家谷お話しますけれどもだいたいどんな
言葉でも
同じの意味を伝える
伝えることができるんですよねなくなるっ
大
大味ではですね戦略的に見てどの言葉でも一緒なんですよ
同じ意味を仲達できるんですよ
ただその先日がですね
実際に具体的にどうやってソヌ
その意味をですね伝わるかっていうのがそれぞれの言葉では違います
だから和え
次の新しい外国語を勉強するときにそのいろんな細かい点においては違うんだという風
に言う
いうことはですねよくその
化合してやらないといけません
そしてもう一つなんですねこれまた態度の問題なんですけれども
その自分がミュー長に話せることをいつも話したいと言う
そんなそこまで d その言葉をました
6ことだけを考えてそしてましたできないとかそれを忘れましたとかそれまあは咲く
わからないとかそういうことが起こるときに非常にもその+0トップ
管理いってねその
その何ですか絶望するようなね胎動は避けるべきです
それからねじゃあ一つは何が違うかというのはね
まず1つはですねやはり遠いですよね works
英語の場合は i5融合ひどうざー
日本の前は日本語の場合はそれがないでしょういきます
上っていきますはたちがいきます誰からいきます
問題ないんですこの場合は
その
同医師の300ねによって違ってくる
場合によっては点数にも違ってきます
それがねそれになれるのはですねものすごい時間かかりますそれがいくら説明を見ても
それは
週間にはならないんですよ
ねえ
非常に流暢に英語の話せる色ある日本人だけじゃないけれども
移動という
いうが多いです哀悼一号豪雨
アイドル融合デイゴ初子バッジ豪雨それが分かっててもいい事言うんですよ
それは頭脳はそこまで慣れるのは時間かかる
それは+プレーリーにならないように
続けてもう練習しないといけません
矛盾点施設なんですね
英語の場合は初めてその ion air
ime の愛編ガーン i heading 強引
ion
その辺の速雑な9月はね
それはいくら説明見てもですね分のたくさん聞いて呼んでね
慣れるまでにはそれを分かってからねじゃあ正しく使えるかというのはそれはないん
ですそれは私の逆の場合は日本語を勉強した時に行ってあげまーすやってくれるやって
もらおう
応用ようなことはね
慣れるにはですねものすごい時間かかります
いくら説明何回も何回見てもわからないです
それだからなれるんですね
を消せるは同市もう一つが非常に違うのはそれは
頃はで言葉の順次ですねルンバ
あの
日本語の場合はね
omar をオーナー方はですね後ろに来るんですよ
私が何が皆にを考えます
英語バージョン icems あ
で多くの日本人はですねルートに英語話てもですね
トゥデイが合図 day i スイングの言うんですよ
それは間違いです
食にもまだそれず頭からですね最初勉強するときにまずこれわかるためにね
読んだり聞いたりするときにそのアイフィットがオウムな道師が始めてくるというのは
ね
森は知っておかないとかんですよ
そこまで流自然的にそこまで話せるようになる
にはね時間かかるけれども少なくても所有のがあるって言うことをよく理解しないと
いけません
それは同比だけじゃないんですよまあ同社が開いフィンガー
this asa ni ずボック
愛煙強引2ですと私が店行きます
英語の場合はアイアン強引だからどちら初めに来る日本語は後ろ
それだけじゃないず英語の場合は
えーいの r 2
女マネー iaea は it works web キャンペーン
日本は金をその
も設けるために涙にために何何だから
何何のに英語違うん
ウィーク rs ran のに
ああああああああ犬 e 2
ブーバーれ家へ alea アーレア
ハウスは初めに行くその言葉の順次はよく考えて
だけども慣れるには時間とか
あとはですね英語の場合は
難しいと思うのはその細い
パーティバープロポジション endear チェーンフィッティングのハウス
ファームハウスアートハウズ
それはねー
それは時間があるけれども間違っても大したん
大切じゃないです夢がわかる
あの街月でも相手が
ラプラプ税収が難しいと思います日本人にとっては
a あり腰それ日本語にはないかな
ゾコンカーペコーン a
いやそれはそれもですね時間の問題であんまり気にしない方がいい
いくら説明見てもわかりにくいと思います
で
そんなに意味に影響しないというのは日本語中国語ロシア語
そういうありこのない言葉が多いですからそれ本当は
近藤必要じゃないんです
選挙のプロ
うんのテーブルの上の本品
ワンドロップボックスファイルボックス分かりませんだから
そりもなる問題だから英語の場合はならず
ルーズリーフ5スティックティーハートローズ s の音付きます
僕 web
ボキャブラリーそれ大事まあたくさんも読んでー
そしてだんだんとその2英語の後キャビンの場合はウイルスとボーイズのコレクション
南蛮バーガーバーって売っにょ場合は
感じですからその
ほんでぃさん
あるんですよ
単語と単語の関係がわかりやすいんですけども
英語でもそういうかアイゴはですねスペインあーから英語のヒアリング
まもなくなるからそれはまあ第1その each それに対して皆さん興味がありまし
たが入ってください
そしてご自分の意見ご自分の経験も
ぜひの
てくださいじゃあですねまらー